listen up bro fans have found a strange
criticism of the dialogue in the way of
water and you'll never guess what it
could be unless you've been living under
a giant rock on a planet far far away
you were probably aware that James
Cameron's Blockbuster Avatar the way of
water that's at theaters across the
United States we are back together 13
years later pretty exciting yeah it is
right the online discussion around the
movie has been mostly favorable with
plenty of Praise mixed in with a few
critiques namely the relatively thin
plots and more than three hour run time
the second installment in James
Cameron's planned 5 film Arc also earned
kudos for the stunning visual effects
and this criticism of Earth's wasteful
capitalist ways
heartbeat sound like Mighty however some
fans are pointing out that a particular
scripting choice is a best and
intentionally hilarious and the worst
kinda destructing much of Avatar the way
of water centers on the children of Jake
Sully and natiri as well as the
teenagers of the seafaring Mets kaina
Clan while the dialogue seems to be one
of the most criticized aspects of the
film in general the frequent use of the
word bro by the male teenage characters
had many viewers cringing in their seats
in the official discussion thread for
the film on the movie subreddit one user
wrote bro I lost count of how many times
they called each other bro another user
observed that's how teenagers talk love
there one redditor was less gracious
commenting that the overuse of bro was
their biggest gripe about the movie they
said why do they talk like that they
wouldn't have gotten that from Jake he
is too old to talk like that seems like
an old man writing garages to relate to
a modern teenage audience
how do you do fellow kids James Cameron
is 68 and co-screen might say Rick Jaffa
is 66 of course so this user seems spots
on with their analysis another user was
more accommodating to the choice and
wrote that's actually how people talk
I'm 28 and I still start a ton of
sentences with bro when I'm hanging with
my friends why will not every commenter
volunteer at their age those up on more
modern slang asserted that teens really
don't say bro anymore one redditor said
bruh is the actual saying these days the
point raised the Bell so that teenagers
would have learned such language as
valid these characters do not have
American pop culture to learn from and
it's a bit of a stretch to think that
Jay could have been calling his own Sons
bro while they were growing up though
that's not entirely out of the question
as one Reddit user posited well they did
learn an entire language from a
self-proclaimed Jarhead even if Jake
himself didn't instill the usage of the
word bro in his kids there are other
justifications for its frequent usage
Jake isn't the only earthborn being
living on Pandora among the navi a few
of the scientists featured in the first
film including fun favorites Dr Norm
Spellman also chose to stick around the
planet in the wake of the first battle
with the sky people Jake's children and
spider are shown to have a convivable
relationship with these English-speaking
humans so it's possible they could have
picked up on their slang over the years
that would also explain what a slang
feels dated if adults like Jake and
Norma their only reference for American
culture another potential explanation at
the beginning of the film Jake narrates
to the audience that he understands the
navi language so well that it may as
well be English which essentially
becomes a convenient workaround for the
movie's English dialogue who do not know
the sea we will learn your ways if
that's the case perhaps the English
we're hearing isn't actually what's
being said and bro is a translation of a
more appropriate Navi word one reddish
user even attempted to figure out what
the navi equivalent would be writing I
looked up a translator brother in Navi
is to smukon I cannot decide what I like
the thought of more of our hearing aids
in their native language mukan can and
to some what's a smoo I like to smoo it
sounds silly
[Music]